hey everyone welcome to Harry Potter
Theory today we're going to be looking
at muggle wizard Affairs throughout
history when we crack open our history
books and take a look at famous events
and conflicts between Muggles in The
Wizarding World you might be surprised
at what you find before the
international statute of Wizarding
secrecy which was established in the
year 1692 Wizards weren't exactly
unknown although even at that time many
considered the concept of witches and
wizards outlandish there were plenty of
people who had first-hand experience
with members of The Wizarding World in
fact in different corners of the world
at varying times entire countries were
swept into anti-magic crazes that
threatened to destroy almost every magic
using man woman and child in their
Community today we're going to take a
look at some of these events and their
long-lasting legacy as we discuss the
history of Muggle and wizard Affairs if
you think of the modern world then the
fact that Muggles and the Wizards don't
intermingle is a foregone conclusion
after all the ministry of magic had
worked tirelessly for centuries in order
to keep their constituents as Secrets
but when we look back in time to the
earliest records we find a very
different landscape in the official
history of the Wizarding World the
earliest date documented is 382 BC
that's the year that a Roman ancestor of
Garrick olivander the wand maker from
Diagon Alley in Great Britain created
their first branch in ancient Rome
there's more than a 1 000 year gap
between that date and the next listed
event in official visiting records so if
we were to try and guess what happened
and how The Wizarding World might have
interacted with Muggles of that time
will have to rely on our detective
skills
sometime around the 10th Century all
four founders of Hogwarts were born
after meeting they founded the school in
a remote region of Scotland but their
Union was short-lived eventually Salazar
slytherin's intolerance and his hatred
for Muggles and mud Blends Rose to a
boiling point when the other three
founders decided they could tolerate No
More Southern took it upon himself to
leave and continue his study of Magic on
his own but when we looked closer at
Southern's Life we'll find that his
hatred of the non-magical people of
Britain was more complicated than simple
Prejudice and was a direct reaction to
what was happening around him in muggle
records of that time they almost
exclusively wrote about magical
creatures Wizards and witches as evil
beings and with the eventual rise of
Christianity across Europe Mughal
histories were taken up by monks and
theologians not willing to allow another
Power structure stand in the way of the
growing authority of the church these
clergies took Pagan writings even
further and declared many magical beings
were connected to Satan even before the
Salem Witch Trials of the 17th century
the penalty for magic was often death
so Salazar's Prejudice although
problematic for enrolling mud Bloods at
Hogwarts wasn't without reason
through the Dark Ages and later Middle
Ages witches and wizards continued to
straddle the line between communities
the laws regarding concealing yourself
for Muggles weren't as Ironclad as they
would later become in the 18th century
when the ministry of magic was founded
in this early time non-magical humans
seemed to be painfully aware of the
magical world often muggle sources
described dragons Manta cores and other
ferocious beasts that preyed on their
communities even the official histories
of the ministry of magic cite that a
reason for relocating many magical
creatures to Wildlife reserves was at
least partially due to their predation
on non-magical people while Wizards and
witches could easily defend themselves
with their Mastery of spells and potions
pre-industrial Muggles rarely hand
access to weapons that could slay
magical beasts as the years passed an
occasional witch hunts Rose and fizzled
out across the world the international
Wizarding Community became more and more
connected while trying to build their
International Collective their
leadership couldn't help but worry about
the increasing number of hunts and
executions that targeted witches and
wizards in the 1300s in response to the
popularity of burning witches at the
stake the flame freezing charm was
developed prior to this Wizards and
witches were just as vulnerable to death
by burning as anyone else but if they
used this charm they were invulnerable
to Fire and in fact it made the Flames
feel Pleasant much later in 1492
Nicholas de Mimsy porpington found
himself on the wrong end of an ax just a
day prior he'd been standing in line
behind a noble woman lady grieve and
when he tried to fix the poor woman's
teeth he gave her massive tasks instead
it was easy for the local authorities to
spot that he was a wizard so they
arrested him threw him in jail and then
planned to chop his head off in the
morning as the students of Hogwarts
would learn much later when the ghost of
Nicholas recounted his tail it took the
Executioner 45 attempts to cut
Nicholas's Noggin off but even then a
strand of Flesh held it to his neck only
50 years earlier a French woman named
Lizette de Lepa was also discovered
using magic and sent to The
Executioner's block but unlike Nicholas
Lizette wasn't stripped of her wand
before being tossed into jail as she
awaited her death she transformed
herself into a white rabbit and lapped
out of the cell as these hunts for magic
users continued the persecution of
wizards and witches by the non-magic
community presented other problems
during this time quidditch became the
most popular sport amongst a Wizarding
youth but the sight of young men flying
around in the sky aboard their
broomsticks often would create hysteria
amongst nearby Muggles and this
eventually would lead to more witch
hunts and executions in order to combat
this local quidditch officials declared
that no match could be played within 50
meters of a muckles dwelling when this
proved to be insufficient it was
increased to 100 meters but even that
didn't stop wandering Muggles from
spotting the games the 100 meter limit
was eventually increased to the maximum
quidditch could not be played in any
area where Muggles could see it and the
penalty for breaking this rule was quite
harsh even by medieval standards
although for many witches and wizards of
this era they would have chosen no other
time to live in the 15th century a
cunning witch named Hannah cockleford
used her ability to cast charms to
sabotage local Nobles at one point
during a public jousting match between
the Despicable Earl of paunchly and a
child hanacosta charm shielding the boy
the blunt force of the impact sent the
Earl flying and reduced his mental
capacities to that of a toddler for the
rest of his life
their ability to intervene in the
Affairs of Muggles must have been
gratifying had witches like Hannah lived
much later during the time of the
ministry of magic they would have been
far more constrained in their ability to
Dole out Justice by the 17th century the
clash between the Wizarding World and
Muggles seemed to be at all-time highs
in the new world the Salem Witch Trials
were in full swing for two full years
the Puritans who lived in Salem
condemned nearly two dozen witches of
horrible crimes although many of the
people who faced death weren't actually
members of The Wizarding World a few of
them were in fact witches and to this in
addition to the witch hunts back home in
Europe weighed heavily on the minds of
leadership in Britain at the same time
some of Mary Lou bare Burns ancestors
paraded around the continent as members
of the scourers these were Renegade
Wizards who would take any job for money
ranging from bounty hunting to selling
innocent witches to Crazy Puritans who
wanted to kill magic users within the
same Century a criminal wizard
terrorized Muggles in England using a
special unlocking charm a thief named
Eldon Els rickel went on a robbery spree
in London stealing more than he could
ever need before ultimately dying at the
hands of his own nundu all of these
events eventually drove the Wizarding
Community to sign the international
statute of Wizarding secrecy which
declared all magical beings must conceal
themselves from Muggles this was the
last desperate plea by the leaders of
the Wizarding World to try and protect
themselves and their children from
persecution at the hands of the
non-magical community after all they had
pleaded with William III and married II
to enact new laws to protect witches and
wizards but they refused with the
passing of the new statute violence
against Wizards dropped significant
the long list of new rules which
included wearing muggle clothes when out
in public and barring Wizards from
participating in muggle Sports dulled
the lives of many Wizards and witches
many notable families including the
malfoys complained that they shouldn't
have to live like this hiding from the
people they considered to be their
inferiors but the results didn't lie for
the first time in centuries witch hunts
started to decline and arrests for use
of magic were at all time lows the newly
formed Ministry of magic in Britain and
its sister agencies in countries around
the world made sure that every nation
kept their magical communities concealed
and although there were a handful of
breaches it was nothing that a few
forgetfulness charms couldn't solve from
the 18th century to the modern era the
lives of Muggles and wizards were
successfully separated so much so that
Muggles by and large considered kids
witches and magical creatures as nothing
more than fairy tales and that's it for
this video if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live